[Music]
we're walking out to your music to your
tunes it's a big party out here it is I
didn't expect it in the movie of course
vacation is a big deal are we going a
cool summer plans any summer vacations
for you plan D I know you got a birthday
coming up at the end of the month I do I
may be working in the movie there's the
happy song do you have like a go to
happy song that you know I love to
listen to this is me greatest showmen
when you came right on anything well
yeah good I love it
[Applause]
[Music]
I love how you opened up recently saying
that you just like to enjoy life and I
sort of dwellings that stress you well
I'm just kind of step back a bit
I'm I enjoy my life I don't really think
about anything that causes me stress
anymore which is really nice I don't
even live in LA anymore I don't pay
attention to trying to get people to
like me as much though I think in
general I think I'm it's important just
to remain positive and I don't know I
come out I'm at that age where I feel
like that's what matters is making sure
I'm healthy and people are happy that I
love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]